how did you end up with someone in
Australia like how what do were you just
decide you just wanted to live there for
a minute well you know as one does it's
a rough commute for a relationship
that's all I'm saying like no we met
um as one does on a Nat Geo expedition
to Antarctica
incredibly there's an app for it guys
just look out no wait what is that true
yeah it is true okay I was like are you
being sarcastic no no I did we met on it
on it we're on a ship to the Antarctic
and uh that's how I met him so I was at
one of the Earth this is like a movie it
is a movie yeah that's not a penguin
like that's yeah that's a really hot man
I'm gonna marry yeah that's awesome I
love I want to go to Antarctica that
sounds fun well I did I loved I was
obsessed because of everything that's
happening with the world I was like I
got to see the art I went to the Arctic
before it's gone before it's gone yeah I
want to see there was an iceberg I saw
Portage Glacier in Alaska and it's like
completely changed like you know I saw
it years ago yeah yeah melting so um but
it was incredible it was an incredible
trip and then bonus you know found the
love of my life pretty good trip I think
it's a pretty solid Penguins check
Penguins check ice check magic yeah I
like that
[Music]
[Applause]